strategic outrage this morning about the
legitimate political discourse i don't
know if you guys seen uh but the
republican parties are is eating
themselves i guess when you are the [ __ ]
sandwich you eat the [ __ ] sandwich
sometimes so um this morning we're gonna
talk about how the republican party is
going in complete disarray
it it is clear now uh where their wedge
is
um and their wedges that they suck and
it sucks to suck
so let's let's go after them today you
know let's not waste any time let's
let's just bring let's bring rachel and
rachel how are you
i'm doing tony it's it's monday another
week to save democracy we're getting
audio i'm not getting audio here no
what happened there we go there we go
now i can hear you there we go all right
i was sorry about that we had audio yes
yes well my my headphones weren't
weren't operating for how are you this
morning it's full of monday and happy
[ __ ] monday morning
dude yeah mondays suck right right right
so so over the weekend we saw
the republican party clearly clearly
they're in disarray clearly they're
broken uh clearly they can't decide what
type of fascism um you know there's a
lot of people that they love fascism
over there they're just not exactly sure
exactly what type so they call it they
called it what do they call it what do
they call it
i'm sorry
a legitimate political discourse
yeah yeah that's what they called it
that's what they call it so they think
they think january 6th you know that's
just that's just ordinary protesting
right it's just like just discourse so
explain to us why they why they are
messaging it this way and explain to us
why this is horrible for them and why
and how we can take advantage of it yeah
well you know tony when i enter into a
debate i always bring with me a few
cans of bear spray
you know and then beat my opponent in
the head with uh flagpoles and stuff you
know
yeah right i mean yeah that's that
sounds legitimate it sounds like
political it sounds political and it
also sounds you know like discourse
right
we're going to see them go to court and
argue that this is protected first
amendment speech to beat the cops with a
mega flag
right right well you know that you know
the great part is is they were beating
they were beating them with a flag
that's like blue lives matter right
oh yeah that's really special yeah i
have that like stored away in the rachel
vault
oh really
you know i i
understand like all the good [ __ ] you're
not gonna see any of that until fall
because i'm gonna [ __ ] hammer them
where they don't have time to react and
they have to react in campaign time you
know what i mean
so like you get to see [ __ ] but not the
best [ __ ] yeah well right right and yet
the other crazy part is is that
you know here we are it's a year past
january 6th right they have two
republicans that are on the select
committee that are that are you know
tethered to some kind of reality
tethered to some kind of truth
and in in their attempt to delegitimize
those two people because that's
literally what they're trying to do
is de-legitimize anything that adam
kinzinger or liz janey says right like
that's their whole attempt here
it really isn't to censure them or or i
mean it is to punish them but ultimately
adam kinsenger's not re-running so
there's no punishing him at this point
liz cheney is going to run in wyoming
regardless what they want yes i mean and
we're going to make damn sure that she
is financed
right and that she gets to go out there
and make that case and let me tell you
why we want people to do that right
because it's one thing for you and i to
sit here and [ __ ] about legitimate
political discourse
uh but it is the value of having an in
like somebody in the in the tent even if
they don't you're trying to kick them
out um of being able to clarion call and
pull through all the [ __ ] and say no
not partisan at all right that's it's
super it's super value so valuable so
yes you know chaney is a die hard die in
the wool conservatives and honestly we
should be thanking god for that because
like the federalist society and these
constitutionalists are supposed to give
a [ __ ] about the constitution and they
all abandoned it right right so when we
look at a very few very small bucket of
people who were ideologues kinzinger is
not an ideologue right liz cheney is and
and if she was not
deeply committed to the american
experiment in terms of its you know
democratic small or republican
principles then she would not have blown
up her political career to do that right
so
well you know i think one of the most
significant um
symbols from
the the old guard republican party is is
on january 6 this year when they
commemorated the one year anniversary of
the violence at the capitol and the only
republicans standing in the chamber
you know commemorating the violence and
and you know respecting the lives of the
people who lost their lives that day the
law enforcement jesus christ is the law
and order party right
the only the only one was liz cheney and
i think the most significant part about
it not that she was standing there but
dick cheney darth vader himself
flew from wyoming to stand there on the
floor with her and to basically send a
signal to the republican party that hey
hey i'm still here and i am i am telling
you that what she is doing is what we
need to do like he was sending that
signal and and i think that is a
significant um symbol inside the
republican party and i believe that
that's what the rnc and trump want to do
is try to delegitimize you know this is
what this is the [ __ ] trump playbook
right right this is this is how they do
it they delegitimize their enemy they
delegitimize and they try to
delegitimize anything they say that's
the hunter biden laptop [ __ ] and all
that garbage you know they to try to try
to drag they're a political opponent as
if they don't know what they're talking
about or you know whatever and i think
that's that's the liz cheney part of it
but
the most important significant thing for
us
as the left right and our argument going
forward
is they really stepped in it in a couple
different ways because they're like oh
it was political or legitimate political
discourse well if it was and it was
antifa and black lives matter and the
fbi well then what are you bitching
about right like like you can't they
have they want to have it so many ways
so how do we how do we how do we make
sure we have that strategic outrage to
break up that that well i mean it's
hypocrisy but how do we drive wedges in
between their message because their
messaging is all over the map at this
point yeah well i mean here's the thing
you don't do is you don't you don't
develop a plan that's responsive right
so like here's the thing i was already
gonna do this in some iteration but now
they've handed me a phrase like to fund
the police all right and i'm gonna
[ __ ] weaponize the living [ __ ] out of
that phrase tony and my ultimate goal
now i mean my goal was to to somehow and
i tell people what when they ask me what
i do i'm like oh i i've got to try to
get america to panic before there's
really obvious reasons to panic because
if we don't do it preemptively then
we're going to hit that spot and then
it's late and that's what we know from
all of the civilizations that have ever
failed other than you know barbarians at
the gate that's how they do it when
failure comes internally it's because
there's massive signs of serious serious
issue and because of status quo by it
bias which i even have i mean i drive
around oregon i look at i go shopping
and i'm like how in the hell are we
gonna get
you know what i mean so like that kind
of thinking prevents action in time and
so we have to panic people preemptively
and i was going to
you know i'm advocating with the with
democrats you know from the official
democrats all the way down
you have no choice in a midterm cycle
the midterms could be about you unless
you make it about them and they've
handed you
like this perfect condition because
them means fascism lawlessness
disorder autocracy like that you can't
ask for a better [ __ ] wedge as long
as you personalize it for voters and
it's not abstract you know so people
talk about oh we should
we can't talk about democracy it's too
abstract then yeah well you know what
you do is you make it personal right
there's lots of ways to first i mean you
can make curriculum
in k through 12 a completely fake
manufactured scandal crt because it's
not even real and then use that turn
that into a a buzzword that everybody
knows right so you have to first
increase salience and then you increase
a strategic outrage with it by making
one woman sit there and ring her hands
about her daughter being exposed exposed
to black porn in school right like you
don't
make it about the abstract because
unfortunately for us like 15 percent of
the public thinks about others a lot and
that's it and that leaves 85
of people with different values than
progressives okay so like speaking our
values is fine and [ __ ] dandy but the
values i want to speak are the values
that the voters are going to vote either
decide to show up to vote or vote for
the opponent those are the values i'm
concerned with and their values are
pretty much centered around themselves
their family their community so you
really need to make that fear palpable
and real to them well you know
and sometimes i i believe it's going
after their message that that you know
and turning their message around on them
that i i think that's um why some of my
audience likes how i say things is
because i i take their argument and i
turn it you know in the opposite
direction um for instance like the price
of gas the price of chicken the price of
milk um what you say is is do you think
milk
you're gonna worry about the price of
milk now but the price of milk when
fascism takes over you think you're
going to even get milk
what what what on earth makes you think
that they won't choose who gets the milk
like they're already choosing who gets
what and that's what they want to do so
you're worried about the price of milk
now but there won't be a worry about the
price of milk you'll you won't be able
to get milk because they'll be choosing
who gets it and who doesn't that's
exactly right and you might be loyal
dude
right right so
and we've talked about this we did an
interview yesterday and we'll be playing
it this week i believe and we talk about
that in the interview and it's just like
you know with fascism you don't have
your church that you have you don't have
your school that you have you don't have
your community and i was talking with
someone yesterday and i said the the
communities that are going to be
affected by fascism first isn't the
communities that you think it's the
communities that that are going along to
get along now that will be affected the
most because what they'll do is they'll
look for the dissenters in the most
loyal parts of the country right and
that's that's what fascism does because
they're not going to bust into these big
cities where there's a huge diverse
population and start busting up the big
cities they're going to start small and
they're going to start their fascism
small and they're going to come where
you're where you're going along to get
along and everybody started that tony
right i mean that's what we have right
now right coming out of 14 i mean this
is alec the american legislative
exchange council an organization that's
been in operation now for you know 40
years and the democrats still haven't
bothered to even build something that
matches it on the other side and what
alec has evolved to do
well and do it [ __ ] really well and
really efficiently is right model we
call model legislation so stand your
ground that was an alec bill and then it
got put out to 20 25 republican states
you know pre-written and pre-designed
right so we're not in the legislature
coming up with this [ __ ] right it's one
thing and they've already on team
fascism they're using wherever they have
control of state government even in
places that are extraordinarily blue
like virginia to use you know their
power to wipe out the curriculum to put
in uh gop snitch lines narc lines so
that people can mark on their teachers
who dare teach the truth about slavery
in the south right uh so you know the
fascism isn't it is true that most
likely an outcome is going to be a slow
decline of of democracy right what we
see in hong kong and in hungary and
things like that right it's not you know
the idea that we're going to see a big
flashlight event isn't isn't impossible
either right but the more likely outcome
and and this is the trajectory that
ronald mcdaniel the
rnc chairs is hoping for is that they'll
win elections this time largely
democratically guys the midterm effect
is on their side nobody knows that
they're the party of legitimate
political discourse as of today lacking
50 million dollars they're never going
to know that message because right now
that's not the message the democrats
intend to run
and we
really have the very short window of
time to convince people that if
republicans take power legitimately
they're going to do what the nazis did
then use that power to consolidate it
permanently right
democratically and then they take power
and that's we're setting them up
perfectly in this midterm cycle
you know the the structure is setting
them up very very well to achieve that
so do we do we talk to the people who
already know that this isn't legitimate
political discourse or what do we or do
we message to the people out there who
actually went to the polls and voted
against trump and i i mean i think 81
million people voted um
cast her ballot for biden but i don't
think 81 million people voted for biden
specifically so how do we find because i
i think you know i don't know how many
millions of voters it is inside that 81
but how do we find the 81 million people
to tell them that the republican party
thinks that january 6 was legitimate
political discourse because they're
worried about deflategate they're
worried about tom brady retiring right
yeah here's some good news tony is that
we have all that tactical infrastructure
in place it's just not strategically
organized to accomplish that goal and
with the messaging stuff right that you
know coming in and and i i mean what i'm
teaching in messaging is so
different framed in the brain that i you
know when i work with the i do we do the
creative right but we have to put we
have to have executors and we we we're
teaching people have been making ads for
a long time or whatever and copy like
this is yeah but this is how you talk in
a whole different way right because
everything on the left no matter if it
comes out from one group or the other
are done by the same consultant
world and that consultant world it's a
system that's not it's not designed like
the stuff i'm talking about right it's
not operating it's not operating on the
level to win the fight it's not a
referendum message it's not a it's
collective and not personal it's in
every way ineffectual and it was
ineffectual when we were winning in 2017
18 19 and 20 which is what i was telling
people we're gonna [ __ ] win
regardless of the strategy right now
because they suck so bad yeah because
well because this is a vote this is like
the people are going to surge to the
polls
unstimulated right
they're going to have to [ __ ] be
unstimulated by us because we don't
stimulate okay
but luckily for us like that's going to
get done for us
but i and i've always said this as soon
as trump is gone or power switches back
to the democrats strategy we will live
and die by it and this time i mean
literally
right
it is knocking at our door and we've
said this before fascism is here
speaking of political heads i i found
one on the internet i don't know uh
maybe maybe you've seen it before here
um let's let's let's see if we can let's
see if we can pull this up here um
it says it's by um you might know this
person uh rachel bittikov says
legitimate political discourse new ad
legitimate political discourse
republicans are declaring war on the
soul of america uh you don't you know
who this is from i i can't i can't tell
yeah i've never heard of those people
but boy do they have nuts
what let's let's
you want to watch this video let's see
let's see what it says
[Music]
early
light
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
who is
and bright stars
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
get those [ __ ] rachel get those
[ __ ] now here's the thing right
so you got to understand like that
that's for twitter it's for the right
moment
everyone on twitter is willing to sit
for two minutes right right and like my
concern with outsourcing i always say my
stuff is simple simple but not
simplistic and my concern with not
having personal control over how
something like that message gets
distributed is that no one's going to
look at [ __ ] anything that's longer
than 15 30 right right so like that ad
is a really powerful ad and it might be
um editable into a shorter content
because the voice is so nice and so
haunting right right just wanting video
but at the end of the day when you want
to hit those 81 million people tony
about 30 of them are what we call
marginal turnout like and they're and
they're not democrats right these are
the ones i was just talking about
earlier that that that voted against
trump is what you're yeah well they
don't even know about midterms like so
so the gop long ago was like okay we've
got a [ __ ] surge in decline problem
between midterms they figured that out
in
2006 when they got out voted right right
and so like then they were like well you
know let's tweak the system and make
sure that we can hit
turn out cycle the cycle right and like
in 18
i
knew the house was gonna be huge surge
and a lot of it was just that the lines
were 10 years old and they had not been
redone to each party's like best
performance right
but in terms of the senate it was always
a tough match because most of the
defendant seats were real d aligners
they're moving to the right not to the
left and we ran you know
we the republican party has designed a
system to make sure their turnout does
not decline
and they and in 201 in virginia this
system has now been perfected so much
they hit their presidential turnout
numbers in their best precincts so like
when you look at trump performance and
glenn younkin performance it is equal in
their best precincts
right so you're so you're saying you're
saying in
in the districts where where these
republicans are turning out specifically
exactly and what they did with that
strata it's literally the same strategy
i wanted to run in virginia you know and
i was trying to explain to them look
we're gonna shut we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna lose statewide vote like the
statewide total is gonna shed and here's
specifically where it's going to shed in
the state legislature and within these
state legislative seats we actually know
exactly who's vulnerable to shed and to
conversion because a lot of that 10
percent conversion pool is not well
informed they're not they don't know any
of these recent news events that we've
been talking about for two months and
they're imagistic so if the media is
talking about ukraine or russia and and
inflation that's all they that gonna
ever is going to permeate them the top
top level of the news cycle so that's
why my strategy in addition to these
this tweet you know electioneering
system within each state is really
focused on narrative right because
because at the end of the day
it's that generic ballot that we talk
about you know do you want republicans
or democrats to control congress and
what we're seeing in that data
predominantly is a combination of a
depressed like left-leaning independent
field who are
you know they're not partisans and they
and they don't know that the republicans
are screwing with democrats because we
don't tell them so they're they're
turned off they're like man these people
said they were going to fix it and then
they don't you know they actually fixed
100 things but the five things that they
didn't fix is what the newspaper right
right right so i think you it's all
about large narrative and what concerns
me
is that we didn't get that in 2020 the
narrative down ballot should have been
the same as up ballot you cannot trust
these people with your health wealth and
safety they're [ __ ] nuts right
whether it's city council school board
whatever it is all the way down you
don't want these people in charge of
your life because they're [ __ ] nuts
right so how do we so how do we get how
do we get to a point where we have we
have that top line
um
the top line personal narrative right
and so we can't do that until all these
tactical deployments we have are running
on one mission or i can build an
alternative infrastructure that's siloed
out
and can deploy and play
in all of these races so you're talking
about 50 million dollars right so like
operation fire alarm
which i've been running publicly with my
bd appearances and on twitter since the
beginning of december is about getting
people to understand as of today not
only are the fundamentals guaranteeing
us to lose we don't have the right
system in place and we have about three
we really about april to get it in place
so what i'm doing now is really oriented
to waking up the electioneering system
of the left and letting it know as of
today we know what we're doing is it
working because that generic ballot is
still favoring republicans so is it that
our highways is you know that kind of
given out here is it that our highway
system is shitty or we just don't have
one at all yeah we don't have one so
like there's institutions and people
want to give jamie harrison [ __ ] right
jamie runs an institution
okay that institution does a lot of [ __ ]
and it like kind of oversees some of the
electioneering strategy it doesn't run
[ __ ] elections okay right and then
down at these individual committee
levels like those are run by the
consultants basically i mean consultants
come to the these people aren't [ __ ]
election experts right so and they're
not and they're not they're not doing
the top-line
personalized narrative that we're
talking about right they're not they're
not executing they don't know to do that
because the consultant world decides
each campaign is run as a separate
[ __ ] thing dude and that's not how
that's not how the other side works oh
[ __ ] no because like glenn younkin ran
the campaign strategy he ran was created
at the rnc and then given to them or
they you know brought the people in to
run it and they're gonna run that
campaign everywhere right so so let me
ask you so
speaking of glenn younkin could they
have brought any [ __ ] rube with it
with the sweater vest in and done that
yeah do you think oh yeah any anyone not
completely tied 100 percent to trump
tony they could not they needed a rich
one right when when no one other than me
knew virginia could be flipping um they
you know glenn young had to do a lot of
independent financing but they weren't
stupid they understood
like mid-term cycle they [ __ ] aren't
they are well-versed in political
science right over there let me just
tell you and so they knew that it would
be if they're they have a chance to win
on the on the cycle and so they actually
what they did is closed off their
primary process and switched it to a
convention and made it like basically a
party decides convention and gave the
nomination to younken because he was
digestible and very very wealthy
independently so he can finance himself
and get to the point where once the
polls caught up because what i'm trying
to tell people is what what they're
going to see in september right and in
september you're going to see these
close polls you know you may even see
democrats ahead in places like a couple
points by the end of the [ __ ] day
when those ballots get cast if you're
not running this this targeting model
and the right messaging like that the
polling is never going to match reality
right because we're not going to get
that generic ballot that you're talking
about we're not going to we're not going
to see that turnout right because we've
got to get those they get all the people
who have two so like i'm really awesome
[ __ ] friends and they're super
educated and smart people i just hung
out with them for dinner or the other
night i had to bring them up to speed on
every news development of the last month
right because they're because what what
are they what are they worried about
right well they're worried about
democratic collapse because they hang
out with me and nobody gets to hang out
with me and feel good
especially in this timeline right and
they're a perfect little focus group too
because they're all you know they're
democrats or liberals they're going to
vote every time pretty much but like
they they are [ __ ] over the
negativity they don't want to talk about
it they don't want to look at this thing
coming at them people that's natural
human behavior is to ostrich away from
from shitty stuff especially once you've
been forced to marinate into it for a
long time so like these these guys
aren't special i mean they're my friends
but they're not special every [ __ ]
buddy listen this podcast has those
friends who are
you know oh dude they do that and you
can tell they're not following along and
that their heart isn't in it we have to
[ __ ] make sure that those people are
scared shitless not to vote right stay
pissed stay pissed and go [ __ ] vote
as i say all the time conversion pool we
got to give them option a option b
that's the gop is gonna hit us and
they're gonna brand us like the
shittiest [ __ ] thing on earth that's
all that their advertising strategy
accomplishes right brand um
brand breakage branding it's all about
it doesn't matter about the individual
candidate it's the party that they run
against right right right now i i mean i
don't know this for a fact that i
suspect our strategy is even more
candidate specific
right that's right
and what i wanted to do with glenn
younkin and and no one had an appetite
was i was like no [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] if he is moderate dude yeah [ __ ]
him i mean he you know he if he can run
like larry hogan or michael steele and
say this is wrong and the election was
legitimate that'd be one thing okay
but he's not a [ __ ] moderate he's he
was willing to tow the big lie it was
clear that he was biding his time and i
was like let me paint for virginia
reality underneath junkin well [ __ ] it
virginia's already paying already paying
for that no now they're seeing it after
the fact right that's what i'm saying
before right right well that's what i'm
saying though the the the citizens of
the state of virginia are going wait a
second no [ __ ] dude wait a second this
isn't what you said which you know we we
could have called that all day long
every day that ends and why is that that
glenn younkin wasn't going to bring what
he was what he was telling them that
it's all [ __ ] lies i wanted people so
like they want to talk about race and
education and like the mcauliffe team
jumps right into that hole right and i'm
like no [ __ ] if they're gonna
bring up crt let's hit them with dead
kids dude right let's be like look these
are the [ __ ] children all around
america and the teachers by the way that
the republican party murdered with their
pandemic management because well because
they kept spreading the lies and the
[ __ ] so let me ask you this tony if
i had dropped that ad and i accused
literally rick desantis of killing
children do you think the news cycle
would still be focused on c [ __ ] rt
like who is this person accusing him of
being
ahead of a death goal [ __ ]
but that's what i say when i when it's
about the narrative if we're not winning
the narrative in the media then we're
not winning the day right so to me we
have 200 i haven't looked at the clock
260 or something right left to the
election 260 days and for me every day
is like do they talk more about
republicans in the media or more about
democrats and if we don't make sure that
of these 260 days that are left the news
cycle is predominantly focused on their
[ __ ] upness then we're going to lose
this midterm it's just that simple well
you know a good example that and we're
going to talk about this on the other
side of the break with gabe um is this
rogan spotify everyone wanted to go
after spotify and as soon as the rock
entered the chat and the rock is has to
apologize because he realizes that joe
rogan has made complete bio-racist
remarks throughout his career and they
pulled this video from alex jones it
resurfaces
i think patriot takes post it on their
page and all of a sudden all of a sudden
the rock has to
with a lot of class say
okay this isn't right and and all of a
sudden the national narrative goes from
spotify to
oh my god
how how in the hell could anyone support
him saying this racist vile [ __ ] right
like in an instant the message switched
and i believe we can do that with what
you're saying right we can do the same
thing it takes a little bit of that
strategic outrage to flip that messaging
no it takes strategic [ __ ] planning
tony and that that's why not having a
general and a war room with a war
cabinet that's condensed hierarchical
and able to move aggressively and very
very fast is such a strategic
disadvantage to us
that i have no choice but to sit here on
every you know day on twitter and and in
media saying we have to build this war
room right now or we're going to lose
right because otherwise we've got 4 000
people deciding how this is going to get
shook out and there will be no
manipulation of the narrative in that
kind of system right well i appreciate
you joining us today and everyone in the
comments loved your video um you know
like it turns my stomach when i watch
these clips um
let's see a beautiful song over top of
ugly violence um so
that that ad is having an effect so um
if you if you're not following rachel go
follow rachel and strike back over on
twitter and uh you know spread that
thing around the interwebs like herpes
or something yeah maybe yeah like a like
a venereal disease so because if we
don't we're going to have a venereal
disease that takes over our country yeah
i'd rather have herpes than syphilis
yeah well you know that's right i'm
forced to choose well if you gotta if
you gotta flip a coin you know
i'd have to look both of these things up
i'm not going to lock in on her you're
not you're not you're not you're not
going to place your bet is that what
you're saying well you know
you know it happens sometimes rachel
thanks for joining us i hope you come
back next week because i know i know
what'll happen over the next weekend
there'll be some more [ __ ] they'll
give us more more ammunition uh to save
democracy with the ballot so thanks a
lot i like loading up the [ __ ] army
on monday so they have a lot of [ __ ] to
do all week let's do it let's do it all
right thanks for thanks for thanks for
giving us all the ammo for the [ __ ]
army rachel we'll talk to you soon have
a good one stay with us we'll be right
back after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
i always like having rachel on even if
we have to talk about venereal disease
as we're
as we're going to the break you know i
don't i don't know which one i would use
maybe we should uh maybe we should ask
gabe which uh venereal disease he would
he would take on gabe what what venereal
disease would you uh would you choose if
you had if you had an option i mean are
you gonna be all in on one or the other
uh okay well well here's the thing you
know are you looking for something that
you want to live with for the rest of
your life that's like a bit of a
nuisance mm-hmm or what could be worse
uh or do you want something that you
could just cure up and like go away
right
because you know because because
syphilis
while it can have long-term detrimental
effects like al capone neurosci um
right he lost his mind he lost him right
right that's i also have this theory
that that's the same thing that happened
with trump
okay and he he was treated but a little
bit later uh however
uh you can cure it and be gone with it
and then you're done or you can say like
hey i want the herpes route why come on
the [ __ ] are we talking about this
anyway
you can go to the hurting route and you
can have it for your whole life right
right
it stays with you right right it and you
can control it but it stays with you
forever you know it kind of sounds like
it kind of sounds like fascism right
like right there are flare-ups there are
flare-ups right it's always underneath
the surface and it takes one trigger of
something to
to get the switch
and get it going so